are you you look absolutely amazing is
this a new collection yes what is one of
the pieces what kind of emotions are you
feeling right now I mean it's a big
night for you I'm actually very nervous
because I hope that people like my
collection I know it's a little bit
different and I know people who was not
expecting what I was gonna drop so it's
just like I hope it does good and then
I'm about to see so many people so many
celebrities and it's like oh snap snap
snap I'm nervous so people are obviously
gonna like it I mean I hear it's gonna
sell out within a minute that's the
prediction what's your reaction to that
I gotta see it to believe it I gotta say
it's really way I gotta see the numbers
I like to see the numbers I like to see
the facts yeah I also have to ask you
how's your style changed since becoming
a mom I mean it's a big deal she's four
months old now do you feel like you're
more conservative reserved not at all
not at all I don't feel like I gotta
change my style because I had a baby I
feel like the only time I should change
my style is if I have my baby on me like
no I'm not I don't want to wear a damn
thong and walk around my baby Paulie
that's the time but I don't feel like I
gotta change what is offset like as a
dad I mean is he changing diapers he is
changing diapers but like I've been
seeing offset being a dad he already has
three kids so I already fell in love the
way they was a dad already I'm like oh
my god I could have a little one with
this guy he's really good he's really
good guys what more are you talking
about that yeah I totally one more how
many more I want two more two more are
you guys working on that right now
I mean if it's it could be always ahead
of Miss but I don't want them right now
yeah what is your favorite thing about
motherhood and what was the last thing
that culture did that really just kind
of made you laugh um I love everything
about motherhood I like I like
everything like it's just a different
feeling and right now my baby she's a
little sick right yeah she is she got a
little cold stuffy nose but no favorite
though yeah so it's just like those
little things it's just like it's a new
experience for me because it's like I'm
up all night I'm sucking her boogers I'm
making sure that she's breathing I'm
making sure that she won't suck on the
pacifier when the nose and the
stuffiness at the same time it's a lot
but I love everything is she more of a
daddy's girl or a Mama's girl do you
think me you naughty she loves me I love
the more bad things she's just loyal to
whoever gives her the milk when are we
gonna see a picture of culture I know
one day soon yeah why aren't you sharing
her yet I'm scared to share her to the
world you know I'm scared there's so
many people out there but sometimes I
just want to show people how beautiful
how precious she is she's so precious
seriously you've nothing to be scared
about people are dying to see how
beautiful she is
I mean I know it's just there's a lot of
people that just have crazy minds you
know is my little ducky very exciting
week you just announced this new Netflix
competition series what sets it apart I
think what sets it apart is because
we're actually looking for rap artists
you know what I'm saying we actually
looking for hip-hop artists actually
like people do like like you know that
music telling all these dancing things
we're looking for rap artists hip-hop
artists I'm looking for the next I'm
looking for the next cardi be the neck
those are hard shoes to fill I feel like
ah who knows there's there's a lot of
people like me there's a lot of you just
gotta find it but they just got to come
to me
what kind of judge are you gonna be are
you gonna be tough
I'm going to be honest one you know what
I'm saying like sometimes I might really
like somebody or sometimes somebody
might have that face it's like oh I
don't want to break their heart but I
got it so them the truth yeah I feel
like you have so many female artists
here supporting you Iggy Azalea is here
tonight Khloe Kardashian she's not
really an artist but she's here
supporting you what does it mean to have
so many females supporting you tonight
that's awesome
it feels really amazing you know a lot
of people be thinking like it's supposed
to be like a caddy thing and it just
feels good like when other women show
love to each other and they don't know
how much like that means to me though
like that that means that yo you know
what one day you need a kidney I might
give you mines and I barely drink so
they might be mines might be good is
that what kind of woman you are
yeah I love that I wanna be friends with
cardi B yes I look out for people
[Music]